>> Chris: IT'S TIME TO PLAY ETSY PITCHMEN
THERE'S NO VANNA TO BE LIKE --
HERE'S THIS THING (THE REAL
WORLD, RETAIL STORES GO OUT OF
BUSINESS WHEN THEY CAN'T PAY
RENT BUT ON ETSY YOU CAN SELL
WEIRD CRAP AND MAKE NO MONEY AND
KEEP YOUR DOORS OPEN AS LONG AS
THEY DON'T TAKE YOUR COMPUTER.
SO I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU SOME
STRANGE ETSY ITEMS AND FOR 250
POINTS GIVE ME A KILLER TAG LINE
TO HELP SELL IT.
HERE WE GO.
THE FIRST ONE, FURRY PANTIES.
FURRY PANTIES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> THOSE ARE NICE.
>> FURRY PANTIES, EVERYBODY'S
MERKIN FOR THE WEEKEND.
>> Chris: NICE!
NICE!
GOOD LOVER BOY.
YES, POINTS.
RHYS?
>> I'VE GOT ONE.
>> Chris: SURE.
>> NO, SERIOUSLY, I'VE GOT ONE.
(LAUGHTER)
NO, THAT'S NOT IT.
WAIT, THERE'S MORE.
YOU'VE HEARD OF SASQUATCH.
TRY NO SAS-CROTCH!
I BET YOU CAN'T WAIT TO GET YOUR
BIG FOOT IN THERE!
>> Chris: HERE'S THE NEXT ONE.
IT THETE LOOKS KIND OF SAD.
IF YOU HAVE $45 YOU DON'T LIKE
ANYMORE THAT'S WHAT YOU CAN DO
WITH THAT.
SFLOOES
>> THIS LOOKS LIKE THE PERFECT
THING TO LEAVE BEHIND IN THE BED
AFTER YOU'VE HAD A ONE NIGHT
STAND.
(LAUGHTER)
JUST AS YOU'RE HEADING OFF.
A LITTLE TWEET.
>> Chris: BECAUSE THAT COULD
NEVER BE WORSE THAN WHEN WHAT
THEY WOULD SEE WHEN THEY WAKE UP
WITH YOU.
SEE HOW MUCH WORSE IT COULD HAVE
BEEN?
NEXT ONE, LADY GAGA MEAT SHOES.
SIZE 7.
ILIZA?
>> THESE SHOES AVAILABLE AT LADY
MEAT LOCKER.
THE.
>> Chris: NICE!
WELL PLAYED!
GENIUS!
>> GOOD ONE.
>> Chris: POINTS!
NEXT ONE.
CROCHET POOP.
REALLY JUST A PILE OF YARN.
MICHAEL SDME
>> I THINK IT'S TIME TO CHANGE
GRANDMA.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: THAT'S HOW SHE'S